hallo leute ich es wieder mal waren und
willkommen zu einem neuen video auf
meinem blog style channel sagte sie und
sieht aus als ob sie drei tage nicht
geschlafen hätte heute passiert ein
wirklich wichtiger schritt für mich dass
der mega teure beauty produkte und ich
habe viele produkte gekauft und bekommen
die ich im traum niemals angerührt hätte
mich ein bisschen kennt weiß dass das
polnische ostblock blut durch meine
adern fließt und wir quasi das sparen
erfunden habe das vergessen wir heute
mal denn diese produkte sollen teil
eines mega experiments wäre ich stelle
mir nämlich die frage kann ich etwas an
meinem aussehen ländern nur durch die
richtige pflege halten teurere preis
billigere luxusprodukte wirklich was sie
versprechen und werde ich am ende dann
auch zufrieden mit meinem aussehen sein
klingt theoretisch sehr gut ist wilma
sein müssen die wichtigsten fragen des
lebens ich schminke mich abends meistens
ab und cremig dann halt irgendwas ein
unter einer dusche steht auch immer ein
anderes schaffen weil ich noch keins
gefunden habe auch das ich schwören
würde ich denke mit diesem eher lockeren
beauty lifestyle bin ich nicht alleine
hoffeld ehrlich gesagt finde ich das
auch gar nicht schlimm aber und jetzt
kommt das ganz ganz fette aber tief in
meinem herzen macht sich aber eine
schönere haut haben war ich lange haare
und ein lächeln mit denen ich jeden
verzaubern kann den konsum und material
wunsch dann ist das einzige was meinem
leben noch einen sinn gibt
und jetzt könnt ihr auch gerne in die
kommentare schreiben aber bei messe h
das ist doch nur von instagram und nicht
jeder muss so schön sagt jetzt kann es
tatsächlich auch stimmen arbeitet noch
nie ausprobiert ein bisschen mehr
aufwand in mein äußeres zu stecken und
vielleicht existierte draußen eine
version von vanessa die morgens gar kein
make up mehr auftragen will sagt die für
sich haut und das wunderschöne lächeln
leicht aus und vielleicht ein bisschen
der kasse augenbrauen und vollere
wimpern und das glatthaar und und es
kann natürlich auch sein dass ich mich
dann am ende des experiments komplett
gleich fühle auch wird frischer haut und
tollen haaren aber dann habe ich
wenigstens ausprobiert und deshalb
beginnt ab heute das sechs monate sechs
monate beauty experiment und wir werden
es sogar wissenschaftlich analysieren
dann ich habe ein mikroskop was man für
die haut benutzen kann es war jetzt eine
zeitlang trend auf youtube das make-up
gurus ihren schwarm zb mit mikroskop
angeguckt haben diesen beauty blender
oder ihre haut war für luxus beauty nato
zu bieten hat also setzt euch hin und
haltet eure portemonnaies brief fangen
mit dem inneren werten an und zwar mit
den zähnen ihr springen ganz kurz und
eine ganz kleines detail
vor zirka zwei jahren habe ich mich beim
zahnarzt das erste mal über diese
unsichtbaren zahnspange informiert frank
für rund 4000 euro
beide halten und dabei längst nicht
ausgestanden und es war nicht ihr habt
ihr euro ist
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der teil warum ich liebe
influenza zu sein
vor ein paar wochen kam anfangs mai zum
hier und mir die kooperation machen zu
dem abdruck set sunshine smile ist eine
firma die diese maschinen erstellt yahoo
plant einen abdruck zu machen und ich
dachte mir so nein leute ich möchte die
komplette spritze zu machen
ich möchte eine schiene bekommen ich
möchte endlich grabe szene kriegen
wollen wir nicht ein wenn das projekt
starten und dann haben wir hin und her
geschrieben ich habe mit einer person
namens vanessa geschrieben deswegen
konnte das nur was werden das hat dann
einfach irgendwie alles medium gepasst
und anstatt einen abdruck zu machen und
etwas zu schicken wenn ich dann einfach
in die filiale in der friedrichstraße da
bin ich hingefahren und konnte einen 3d
scan von beiden szenen machen lassen ich
habe in meinem leben noch nie so
ausgesehen mann liegt in dem klassischen
zahnarztstuhl und dann kriegt man seine
kamera
und die macht ein komplettes 3d modell
aus seinen zehn leute jetzt bin ich mir
sicher wir leben in der zukunft das sind
meine auf gottes kann man ja gar nicht
zeigen kann jetzt einfach meine
vampirzähne ich hab richtige vampirzähne
und dann prüft ein kieferorthopäde ob
man überhaupt für die warnung geeignet
also auch die zähne sich so verschieben
lassen dass man am ende ein schönes
ergebnis und wenn man für die behandlung
dann geeignet ist dann kann man
entscheiden ob man sie machen und
begabten super ein kurzvideo wie sich
die zähne verändern und das ist möglich
dass lucia und ich habe vor zwei tagen
die schienen bekommen und möchte jetzt
einfach nur noch sehen ich habe es mir
nicht angeschaut ich wollte auf diesen
moment warten und bin mega projekt ich
werde die sechs monate tragen was
wirklich eine sehr kurze zeit aus meine
schwester damals ihre zeit gemacht
drei jahre getragen vorher ist das ein
nutzer kein geld allein schultern
die leute werden jetzt einfach mal
selbst die wurden in 3d druckern
gedruckt könnt ihr euch das also das ist
die zukunft und 22 stunden am tag soll
man sie drin haben und zum essen und
trinken muss man sie herausnehmen und
mein gott ist das ein komisches gefühl
hallo mein name ist verletzt
[Musik]
man sieht ja echt nicht
was in den ferien haben kommen wir jetzt
aber noch mal zu ein paar fans und zwar
eine schiene muss zwei wochen getragen
werden und dann gewechselt und ich habe
videos day für oben habe ich nur neun
schritte und für die untere 15 da möchte
ich auch echt gespannt wie sich mein
essverhalten ändern wird denn ich habe
in letzter zeit sehr fähige snack und
wenn ich mich immer die zähne putzen
muss und das ding arien und raus setzen
muss dann überlege ich mir halt zweimal
ob ich die schokolade essen will
wasser kann man aber mit der schiene
trinken das geht man hat gleich einen
zahnschutz wenn ich mich jetzt auch die
presse packen aber dafür richtig eure
beauty war mir wenn ich auch einen
rabattcode neues level und zwar könnt
ihr mit dem rabattcode nur 120 prozent
auf das start-up druck bekommen was 49
euro kostet jetzt kommt zu
unangenehmeren teil der nicht ganz so
unangenehm ist denn beim zahnarzt ist
immer noch werte teurer und zwar kostet
ganze prozedur 1899 euro inklusive 200
euro für den kieferorthopäden aber da
bekommt ihr mitmachen oder barcodes 100
euro geschenkt leute leute ich bin jetzt
ehrlich zu euch ich wollte schon immer
einen rabattcode haben natürlich jetzt
mal 1899 euro nicht immer so rum liegen
deswegen könnt ihr eine ratenzahlung
machen von 48 monaten und wenn man mit
allem durch ist ein wunderschönes
lächeln hat dann bekommt man für 79 euro
eine ried-trainer schiene die man in der
nacht tragen kann und sie hätten die
zähne gerade sondern hielt auch davor zu
knüpfen so und ich muss jetzt noch zum
clown und los dreh und wir sehen uns
jetzt gleich wieder für mich ist so ein
paar schon später es ist nicht aus
sondern der nächste tag wir haben jetzt
eine woche 18 30 gedreht und danach
sogar futter weiterzumachen aber ich
dachte das gar nicht so schlecht an
diesem tag zu drehen denn ich konnte
diese dinge gewöhnen niemand beim dreh
ist aufgefallen dass ich es überhaupt im
mund habe außer in der kamera weil man
sieht dass meine zähne einfach glänzend
als ob sie mit vaseline eingespielt
werden
deswegen musste ich immer den oberen
teil rausnehmen schlafen ging auch damit
aber ich bin ab und zu macht aufgewacht
weil ich geträumt habe etwas gegessen
habe und ich muss mich immer wieder
daran erinnern dass in den zehn haben
und dass wir uns diese schiene tragen
das war echt ganz willkommen wie jetzt
aber zum nächsten produkt als nächstes
kam uns um dieses kind das hier habe ich
das hier die von amazon zugeschickt
bekommen ich bin ja ein richtiger beauty
blog macht es die box das ist das gerät
es hat verschiedene stufen
ich sag jetzt mal nicht noch verändert
da kann man seine reinigen intuition ein
machen dann machst du was zu rückstaus
und zwei jungs funktionen und dachte
okay sie sollte auch ein kleiner jungs
spende haben sie kostet 90 euro
meine dm bürste kostet 27 wenn man sich
geeinigt haben brauchen wir unbedingt
eine maske das habe ich auch mir bei
amazon aussuchen können ich wollte
unbedingt wissen ob es gut ist denn es
kostet 85 euro und 9 cent
ok damit mich jetzt nicht gerechnet die
sich mal das heißt jede anwendung
mathematik kostet drei euro
wer schön sein will muss auf jeden fall
und geld haben in meinem kopf ist es so
wenn etwas teuer ist dann muss es ja
funktionieren das ist aber ein sehr
altes denken ich mach mit einem weiter
wir machen damit weiter das habe ich auf
einmal zu bekommen
das kostet 2 38 euro
es macht falten an den augen will also
ich bekomme schon langsam diese fallen
an den augen ich bin immer noch weit weg
von alter haut aber wenn man damit ja
früh anfängt sieht man gleich mal jung
aus das wird definitiv das thumbnail
tito und leg mich das große balance
jahrgang
[Musik]
ja zu einer strengen augen partie
ja es gibt natürlich noch bayerisches
band hier läuft dann so den ganzen tag
damit unsere punkte holen jetzt vergesst
diese brille
ich habe nämlich viel krassere ferne zu
rücken als ich das gesehen habe nicht
ich weiß nicht mal ich weiß bis jetzt
nicht was es ist
es sieht aus wie ein puder und led
thermo aktuelle des marktes und jetzt
spielen wir eine runde rate den preis
wie viel hat das gekostet
[Musik]
78 eur 95 also kelly mit seinen 400 euro
politiker weg ist aufladen kann man aus
natürlich ist auch wichtig wenn man ein
bereinigtes hat dass man sich danach
endlich fliegt mit einer 140 euro teuren
creme von la mer ich wusste nicht dass
wir alles gekauft was so teuer ist mäßig
willst du mich veräppeln alle leute aber
das trieb von 250 euro wenn die mich
nicht mega preis dann weiß ich auch
nicht ich habe im internet gelesen dass
sie halt auch gut gegen rötungen sein
soll also viele leute schwören auf diese
creme nichts verschwenden 150 euro nicht
halt original die geschichte fing diese
bequem
ich weiß die richtige ist die nasen oder
wie diese kinder kommen aus diesen
kleinen döschen 141 euro so und da
zugetragen reinigungsschaum 78 95 habe
quasi ein schnäppchen gemacht
okay die ist ja wenigstens mal eine
normale größe her ja damit gleich mit
unserer skin care sind wir jetzt fertig
aber wir haben natürlich auch noch
augenbrauen und wimpern und die wir uns
kümmern müssen und dafür habe ich das
weltberühmte revital esch geholt einmal
für die wimpern und einmal für die
augenbrauen
da der grüne star habt benutzen tropfen
die diesen wirkstoff haben der auch hier
drin ist davon werden die augenbrauen
was machst du die news an diesem kranz
land bremen mal hier lang
wo es schön kühl jetzt kommt es halt für
haare im gesicht
was ist wenn ich es mir hier die ganze
zeit drauf machen
[Musik]
das habe ich auch selbst gekauft für die
bim plan 88 euro und für die augenbrauen
95 also auch bei knapp 200 euro für
haaren bekomme ich ein applausometer
stelle ja ich weiß ich bin ein idiot
kommt der moment an dem ich es bereue
vielleicht gibt es ein blick zurück
weiter geht's mit einer eher tragischen
geschichte und zwar dem ihr das ist park
und der stand was man sich nach
stammbuch in diese flasche packende
knapp 126 euro gekostet läuft bei den
usa dazu habe ich noch eine shampoo in
der gleichen größe gestellt was niemals
an kamps deutschen zurück gekriegt das
kam niemals an beißt er mich mit
produzieren ich hoffe tatsächlich das
mit dem condition mit dem charme
funktioniert meine haare wieder ein
bisschen gesünder aussehen zu lassen
denn bis jetzt benutze ich halt immer
nur den emscher
also auch nie irgendwas speziell für
mich ausgesucht und ich sage oh das wird
nicht funktionieren
deswegen ja und jetzt kommt der beste
teil denn wie erholen unser kleines
mikroskop ich möchte unbedingt wissen
nie meine haut voraus dann haben wir
nämlich auf ein wichtiges kölner nach
ergebnis natürlich ist auch der
allgemeine look wichtig aber
wissenschaftlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]